he's our low white play-by-play boys for
NBC sports with the Premier League he
grew up in Leicester City he lives just
outside the city chances are he had a
late night in the city and Arlo is kind
enough to join us where are you right
now Arlo I'm at home Dan good morning
and warning to everybody I'm about to go
and collect my little girls who have
been indoctrinated into Leicester cities
ways from school and we're heading for
the stadium just to see what's happening
I feel a calling and I need to be there
we'll be there in about an hour's time
what was the celebration like last night
well I was on the road because it's been
an incredibly intense three days we did
three games in three days and the voices
somehow held up under the strain so we
were in West London calling the the
Chelsea against Tottenham battle last
night and I say battle because it was an
extraordinary 90 minutes of football you
had taught them who needed to win to
stay alive in the title race against
their hated rivals Chelsea who were the
current champions who'd had a nightmare
season but the last thing they wanted
was to see top them succeed and win the
title so they did a favour for Leicester
City now a 2-2 draw they were two goals
behind they were tackles fouls yellow
cards it had everything so whilst
Leicester were celebrating I was on the
motorway on the freeway driving back so
I find it's about at about four am
exhausted but exhilarated after an
incredible night if you were gonna try
to capsulize Leicester City for those on
the outside looking in where they rank
you know I know we'd like to Americanize
and say you know what this reminds me of
I don't think there is something that's
a parallel to this so I thought put it
into your words what Leicester City is
what they accomplished I've been racking
my brains down and I heard you talk
earlier about you know the equipment
being Kansas perhaps as a American state
or town Lester's exactly right in the
middle of England it's in the heart of
England but it has the m1 motorway the
main artery that goes up about the
country from London to the north people
in the north thing the Leicester focus
on the south from the south and that's
on the north
we have very little identity we don't
have an accent that you can place like
you know English people's cows is from
Liverpool Jordi's from Newcastle cockney
from London Manx from Manchester they
open them out of in a sentence you can
place them geographically in England you
can't do that with people from Leicester
you drive by the place on the m1
motorway so it's a city that's always
struggled really for identity bigger
towns nearby goodness means we have to
hear one more favor of Robin Hood from
Notting of 30 miles away it's been
driving us up the wall or the firming
him is the second city that's 30 miles
away they've stolen a Lester's thunder
so this is Lester's chance to shine and
and they're taking hit and grasping it
with both hand in sporting terms it's
very difficult to come look at analogy
because you don't have the motion of
relegation so you don't have a situation
where a year before a team is seven
points away from safety and are going to
be relegated the equivalent of going out
of Major League base or into triple-a
and they put a winning run together they
perform the greatest of great escapes
and they survived by the skin of their
teeth to play another season in the
Premier League to turn that around ten
months later to winning the thing is
just astonishing the closest analogy
I've got is is the 1980 ice hockey type
that beat the Red Machine the Soviets I
mean that was an incredible story but
this 5,000 to one shot is one of the
greatest tales ever in sports and it's
been an absolute privilege to bring it
to the American audience but I also
talked about the miracle and ice was
only one game this was 38 games over the
course of his season so I can be on a
run or you can be in a March Madness you
can get on a run this is 38 it's hard to
be a fluke through 38 games or alone it
is and that's testament to a number of
different factors down here like you say
it isn't a flash in the pan it's such a
long season and unless the fans and I
think football fans in general that are
following this story around the world it
happens so slowly as all as death by a
thousand cuts you have to wait and wait
for this lengthy season he come to his
conclusion I think lots of people unless
they really this happened with two two
games to spare
it's a culmination of a number of
factors a confluence of events no the
Manchester City's that rich club's
United Liverpool Arsenal Chelsea laid a
collective egg between from the season
it's an amazing occurrence that all five
of those clubs were misfiring and at the
same time but then to take advantage of
that a club like Leicester City had to
be perfect to nine and a half months and
that means the ownership they're a Thai
billionaire family that when a duty-free
company because I'm getting involved
with a day-to-day running of the
football club but there there is support
the fans have been astonishing the
atmosphere is incredible the manager
this is washed up Italian no-hoper
Claudio Ranieri coming in and just being
all the players this collection of
journeymen unearth gems that have been
put together this band of brothers who
could just love each other it's just
been a collective so extraordinary it's
hard to put into words they defied the
odds they defied every pundit that said
this was impossible and they've done it
and on Saturday the pleasure of being at
the King Power Stadium
32000 my closest friend and we'll be
listening the Premier League trophy and
until I see it done I don't think I'm
still gonna quite believe it it is
remarkable and they need to be this
story is going around the world and they
need and deserve all the praise that
comes their way because they have put
the town on the map they put the sport
on the map and the Premier League it is
just compelling viewing anyway without
this story but even more so this morning
these are a little white play-by-play
boys for the NBC Sports Group for the
Premier League did you get emotional
you're from Leicester City did you cry I
didn't I didn't and it's been such a
strange experience down because I came
to Seattle to the United States I've had
a love affair with the country for so
many years I just wanted to work and
live there and the Seattle Sounders
offered me a job after 10 years at the
BBC and I thought that let's have a new
look let's go to the United States a
place I've always wanted to live and
work in after various visits down the
years and I thought never never the
twain shall meet again and I managed
I thought at that point to connect with
the fan base I'll come out as unless
this is in fact which you don't
generally do as an announcer thinking
that less they were terrible in the
second division I'm going to work in MLS
for the rest of my career what harm
could it possibly four years later Here
I am I'm going to cat out of the bag you
know so it's been an incredible journey
absolutely incredible journey from
Seattle to to then NBC to do Major
League Soccer and then when NBC bought
the rights to the Premier League my
family and I we came back to do this so
I it has been an emotional sort of time
in between the games but you know
objectivity professionalism
stiff-upper-lip it's in the walks words
for me when I'm behind the mic and I
find it easy to go into that zone and
then maybe have a few sure that's a few
pints of beer after the games and toast
the victories but it's been an absolute
blast doing this and it comes with a
culmination of the weekend what how does
this rank greatest moment in English
psycho history well it's right up there
you know because of the money in the
game these days you know when I first
got into NFL the National Football
League in the 80s I think my first Super
Bowl was was Marino against Montana to
1983-84 we just looked across the pond
at these incredible stadiums these
wonderful teams at the razzmatazz and
the money involved but the salaries of
the players got it was like sport on a
different planet than we were going to
matches in ramshackle stadiums you know
standing up caged in and you saw the
hillsborough very last week as well the
hills were tragedy was a culmination of
a decade of neglect of football fans you
know we've had hooliganism and crowd
control problems and it was just it was
hard work going to football matches and
now you've got this situation where
there's millions of millions of pounds
in the game of football now and it's a
different world and they're powerful
clubs who have fan bases throughout the
world rule the roost because there's no
system there's no draft where the worst
teams get the best college players the
next season the system is there's no
system it's the Wild West
so the teams were the most money that
usually correlates to the most points
and therefore they win the trophies
Leicester City to do this with a
starting 11 with like most weeks costing
around 30 million dollars when
Manchester United would dismiss a plane
and paying that smaller fievel one
player is just remarkable Washington
Forest and form engineer neighbors won
the title having come up from the second
division in the lake 70 they then went
to European Cups which is the forerunner
to the Champions League that we now know
that was remarkable Darby County a small
town near Leicester they wanted in the
seventies but this would be with the
uneven playing field that Lester had to
compete in it to my mind
maybe I'm skewed a little towards the
foxes because of my leanings but to me
it's the greatest story the greatest
achievement in the history of English
football great to talk to you go pick up
your girls and thanks for joining us our
long my pleasure
absolute honor to be on your show down
Frankie med sir our low white
play-by-play voice for NBC Sports Group
Premier League the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience